um tell me about
uh there was the the the the Martin
Lawrence Danny DeVito soundtrack I
forget the name of the movie yeah um
what's the worst thing Could Happen
what's the worst that could happen but
it sparked your biggest solo hit cuz I
remember being a kid and like I could
not turn on the [__] radio without
hearing music was huge it was everywhere
I couldn't believe it I couldn't I to me
again music was not supposed to leave my
downstairs that guy my friend Bernard he
stole my CD crazy I played it for him
and he stole it out my CD player then he
went to California went to a Clear
Channel um the the the record convention
and then I'm sitting on the steps of the
W A lady comes down and says yo your
song with Marvin Gay is great so now you
can imagine me Kevin I'm losing my mind
like what is she talking about and who
told her about this crazy the whole
convention had her direct record next
thing you know I go to Miami I'm number
one I'm number one and next thing you
know it just whatever because the head
of Clear Channel I forgot his name was
at the time he he loved it that was it
it was a smash and then Jimmy iven of
course I worked with him before 95
M he was
like um for the soundtrack yeah so the
soundtrack was moving but Clive Davis
and Tommy Mata was like listen what do
what do you want so I went to Tommy Mata
say yo $2 million you know whatever like
that but now went to cl cl said tell
Eric I give him $4 million and I give
him half as far as 50/50 me and him he
make money I make money wow that's how
huge the song was was that because was
there already a buzz for it before it
like officially was like the buzz yeah
because it happened in La okay so
everybody had already heard the record
and knew it it was already being passed
around was was that was at the everybody
that was at the convention it's Clear
Channel so it was so then you have to
worry about like okay as long as y'all
go get this cleared cuz then you got to
clear it but that's what happened yeah
we got stuck up because it was a
$150,000 to the estate and then 50,000
to the lawyer so it cost 200 to clear
the record Y for the whole process such
a great record though man yeah but it
was worth a 200 cuz it it gave me it
gave me it gave me a career it gave me
another half of my life yeah cuz then
after that you have react and all of it
re nobody nobody knew that I was going
to come back with something like that
afterwards because again when something
that big happens they like oh no that's
it for him and I came right back mhm
with with that yeah for sure man um talk
to me uh look at Kev Kev you know sh go
ahead Kev yeah I'm hipop man um